[Musik]
seit dem ersten tag von putins krieg
gegen die ukraine bericht mehr nahezu
ununterbrochen darüber dabei gab es
dramatische momente emotionale sogar
skurrile momente gab es vor allem aber
haben wir mit vielen menschen gesprochen
viele außergewöhnliche menschen
kennengelernt und diese ganz besonderen
momente und menschen möchte ich ihnen in
dieser spezial sendung darüber einem
monat krieg noch einmal zeigen und einer
der in gewisser weise auch dazugehört
ist unser reporter peter titel der in
diesem ersten kriegsmonaten unterbrochen
aus russland berichtet hat es sei denn
er wurde festgenommen einkassiert und
belehrt schön dass du wohlbehalten
wieder da ist peter und was krieg auf
russisch heißt das haben wir auch von
dir gelernt damit hat er aber zum ersten
mal auch den russen erklärt dass seine
armee bei diesem militärischen
sonderoperation in der ukraine wie ich
das nennen muss mario pohl das ist das
mindestziel das mini ziel der
sonderoperation der militärischen
sonderoperation in der ukraine wie ich
das nennen muss nach mehr als drei
wochen riet irische sonderaktion in der
ukraine mich das nennen muss ja
irgendwie verkünden und genau darum geht
es nicht es geht nicht darum wie sich
unsere bundestagsabgeordneten fühlen ob
sie stolz darauf sind dass die lenski
zugesprochen hat sondern dass da ein
volk bei den militärischen
sonderoperation in der ukraine wie ich
sie nennen muss auf geheiss des herren
da hinten also man kann krieg nicht
krieg nennen man kann nicht sagen was
man will trotzdem haben wir dich immer
verstanden was ich sehr deutlich gemacht
hast aber beschreibt uns doch mal die
situation heißt wo ich glaube insgesamt
drei mal bist du da einkassiert worden
und belehrt worden ja das ist jedes mal
im grenzgebiet also in grenzen erfolg
mal war angeblich der grenzstreifen
nicht betreten durften nicht berichtet
wofür drei kilometer großen fünf
kilometer große schilder standen auch
nicht also man muss einschätzen und dann
kommt die polizei oder der grenzschutz
der fsb hier sehen wir eine szene aus
das ist so 200 kilometer nördlich von
rostov am don also unten im süden und an
der grenze dass der flugplatz in der
nähe da kommt da war jetzt die polizei
und die hat uns dann erst verhört und
dann hat sie uns an den fsb übergeben
das ist jedes mal das gleiche vier
stunden polizei vier stunden fsb schnitt
acht stunden unendliche protokolle
unendlich dämliche fragen also wieder
dumme fragen und darum ob das dann ab
dann dort wenn du diese anhörung dann
hat dieser kleine mini prozesse ist also
machen wir jetzt tatsächlich auch in dem
prozess gehabt und zwar wirklich ein
schnellverfahren aber nicht aus der
polizei herausgebracht wurde nach acht
stunden rüber zum gericht und dann ist
mir der dolmetscher verwehrt worden
jetzt der rechtsanwalt war wertvoll und
mir ist das telefonat mit der botschaft
verwehrt worden und dann habe ich mich
irgendwann einfach mit dem rücken zur
richterin gestellt und habe immer nur
gesagt pany mario also ich verstehe
nichts und ich fordere einen anwalt
konsularische betreuung und einen
dolmetscher und das ging dann über
überstunden bis die richterin dann
irgendwann mich dann verurteilt hat aus
lauter verzweiflung weil sie gemerkt hat
das geht gegen die wand und das kann sie
vielleicht mit dem russen machen aber
nicht mit mir und beim ausländer ist
immer noch ein bisschen schwieriger dann
kriegte ich dann eine verwarnung die war
denn ohne geldstrafe völlig völlig
abstrus aber so passieren jeden tag
verfahren und prozesse gegen
journalisten in diesem land ich habe
glück ich kann herausreißen aber nicht
jeder kann ausreisen und wir haben in
dieser sendung vor ein paar tagen
zusammen peter eine frau kennengelernt
wir millionen menschen in der welt
gesehen haben weil sie an aktion gemacht
hatte die sehr sehr mutig war in der
laufenden sendung des russischen
staatsfernsehens sozusagen in der
tagesschau russlands aber in der
propaganda variante natürlich ist sie
als angestellte dieses staatsfernsehens
in die laufende sendung gegangen hat die
quasi gekapert und ein schild hinein
gehalten hinter die verdutzte
moderatorin auf der stand kein krieg das
war eine sehr mutige frau die wir kennen
gelernt haben und wären dann noch mal
rein sander der moment im verlauf des
krieges in dem sie gedacht haben es
reicht ich muss etwas tun egal wie
gefährlich es für mich wird
dass man eine entscheidung die ich schon
lange in mitteltal eigentlich verläuft
ja wenn man sagen könne die letzten acht
jahren unsere staatliche propaganda ist
wirklich immer schlimmer geworden
und die entscheidung in der live-sendung
das war eigentlich was ziemlich spontan
ist
natürlich wollte ich eigentlich was
anderes machen ich wollte auf dem
manegeplatz in der stadt wollte dort
demonstrieren
in der öffentlichkeit gott ist er immer
schwieriger geworden sie wissen
vielleicht dass eine gesetzesänderung
gab dass man also wirklich zu starken
haftstrafen
verurteilt werden konnte wenn man das in
der öffentlichkeit macht da habe ich die
einzige möglichkeit gesehen dass in der
öffentlichkeit so über das ganze hin zu
machen also wie gesagt ziemlich spontan
habe auch meine lage dort geschützt wie
ich hatte dort und fernsehanstalt und
hab gedacht ich muss der welt einfach
mal sagen etwas zeigen ob das am morgen
ziemlich spontan entschieden und
generell bin ich immer davon ausgegangen
dass die russen gegen den krieg
insofern kann ich nur sagen ja wir
dürfen jetzt nicht mehr zulassen dass
die leute permanent diese propaganda
diese gehören
würden
die leute sind so passiv geworden
werden wir alles was sie tun es im
internet zum aussätzigen zu westlichen
agenten erklärt
wichtigkeit überraschte informationen zu
finden
und sie sind opfer dieses informations
kriegsgefahr
es gibt nicht auf fortschrittliche
sollte in erster linie die haben
durchaus zugang noch zu alternativen
informationsquellen
zugang zum teil zur ukrainischen medien
wo sie die wahrheit erfahren können
wie
vor der meinung es muss etwas passieren
was auch gemessen und den russen
vermittelt dass wir dafür eintreten und
das haben wir auch so empfunden das war
eine unglaublich mutige aktion von ihnen
dafür den höchsten respekt hier auch von
uns was drohen ihnen denn jetzt für
konsequenzen
sie wissen
dass man die leitung des präsidenten
hat dass ich ein verräterisches spion
das nicht auf anweisungen auch von
ausländischen
arbeiten also stimmt natürlich überhaupt
nicht ich war wie alle wie viele leute
einfach schockierend verlassen krieg ich
habe mir beschrieben schon wie das klima
ihm gegenüber ist im russischen internet
auch womit ihre kinder konfrontiert
werden aber können sie einmal
beschreiben ich war jetzt selber vier
wochen in russland ich habe für mich
selber wahrgenommen das ist eine
ungeheure beschleunigung gab bei der bei
der repression und dass die stimmung
wirklich ins fast entsetzliche gibt und
auch das gesellschaftliche klima können
sie einmal beschreiben wie in russland
mit kritikern umgegangen wird was ich in
den letzten drei wochen verändert hat
also es gibt auf der einen seite gibt es
diese z propaganda die man auf den
straßen gar nicht wieder findet dass
diese es gibt keinen hype um dieses zeit
aber auf der anderen seite werden
kritikern die türen beschmiert es werden
ukrainer werden ja verhört zu hause wie
hat sich aus ihrer sicht das
gesellschaftliche klima in den letzten
wochen verändert
die mal gesellschaftliche klima ist ganz
friedlich geworden
zu einer spannenden kinder luft die man
jeden tag spüren kann
selbst mal auf der straße einfach nur
den fuß mitunter läuft
merkt man dass die menschen
ihr gesicht geschrieben
ich glaube schon dass das nur ein punkt
ist wo es
vorher mehr zu geben scheint leute sind
verängstigt und wissen nicht wie es
weitergehen soll
die extrem gefährlich ist vielleicht
abschließend noch die frage an sie wie
geht es denn für sie jetzt weiter
diese frage wird mir in jedem winter die
weichen gestellt und ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß nicht was morgen
das kann mir auch niemand sagen selbst
die schamanen ich kann die zukunft nicht
vorhersagen
geht es bis jetzt ganz gut gott sei dank
muss ich sagen und ich habe mich über
jeden tag den ich das werden
wir müssen dann sehen wie sich die
umstände entwickeln frau sie ankara ganz
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie mit uns
gesprochen haben für ihre offenen worte
für diesen einblick den wir sonst die
bekommen hätten in ihrer seelen leben
und das vieler anderer russen in diesem
moment und wir versprechen ihnen wir
werden sie hier am besten nicht
vergessen dass passive aber schon
vielen dank
also eine sehr mutige frau ganz klar
peter aber ordnet für uns noch mal ein
warum das sogar ganz besonders mutig die
frau kommt aus dem system und der
schritt aus dem system heraus so etwas
zu machen ist der größere wenn du über
jahre schon schon dissident bis in die
opposition ist nach so viele kleine
schritte gemacht hast du natürlich auch
über jahre viel erlitten aber der
schritt teil des system zu sein der
propellermaschine zu sein im prinzip vom
vom informations krieger zum
freiheitskämpfer zu werden der ist
größer weil der absturz größer ist und
weil der staat auch er hat dazu schlägt
sie ist jetzt in moskau geblieben sie
ist nicht außer landes gegangen wie
manche andere das getan haben ist es in
gewisser weise ein schutz wenn wir jetzt
und anderen medien auch wenn wir jetzt
öffentlich mit ihr sprechen und damit
sozusagen auch ein signal senden der
westen schaute auch hin es ist die
einzige chance ob es tatsächlich als
schutzfunktion irrt wissen wir nicht der
staat ist momentan völlig außer
kontrolle früher gab's noch ein paar
sachen mit dem man rechnen konnte das
ist momentan nicht mehr da ist ist
willkür aber es ist die einzige chance
auch für sie öffentlich zu sprechen und
auch im westen zu sprechen um selber
gehört zu werden und vielleicht ein
bisschen schutz zu bekommen ein anderer
moment der definitiv hängen geblieben
ist peter ist deine begegnung mit dem
russischen boxer walujew in moskau
gewesen er ist für die russen ja das was
vitali klitschko für die ukraine ist
beide waren zur gleichen zeit
boxweltmeister in verschiedenen
verbänden aber zur zur selben zeit sogar
waren sie
boxweltmeister und was sozusagen in der
unterschied ist beide sind politiker
geworden aber was der unterschied ist
der eine ist jetzt sozusagen sprach auch
von putin kämpft für putin und der
andere vitali klitschko kämpft für die
freiheit wir schauen noch mal ran
sie sind zwei größen der boxgeschichte
nikolai walujew ehemaliger
schwergewichtsweltmeister der double
juni dem weltverband des boxens und
vitali klitschko ex
schwergewichtsweltmeister der double you
bc walujew auch bekannt unter dem
kampfnamen the russian giant also der
russische riese bestritt während seiner
laufbahn 53 kämpfe gewann davon 50 34
durch einen knockout
welche botschaft hatte denn an seine
sportsfreunde boxfreunde
ich würde ihnen vorschlagen ihr handeln
zu überdenken und ihre berühmtheit für
den frieden zu nutzen nicht für den
krieg weil es ihr land ist und ihr volk
leider sehe ich im älteren der
klitschkos sein 2014 keine sportler mehr
ich sehe einen ganz anderen menschen
dieser mann ist kein mann des friedens
ist das muss ich leider feststellen
extremisten faschisten das stimmt nicht
als solcher angriff wert faschisten man
kann nennen nur russen weil die
umbringen frauen kinder zur halle zu
überlisten die diebin wir sprechen für
sich selbst vitali klitschko auch
bekannt als doktor eisenfaust nahm an
insgesamt 47 kämpfen teil der waren
davon 45 41 durch einen lockout
auf einen kampf der beiden hatten box
fans weltweit sehnsüchtig gewartet doch
er kam nie zustande jetzt kommt es
indirekt zum schlagabtausch denn während
witali klitschko als bürgermeister kiews
und seine stadt und das überleben seines
volkes kämpft ist nikolai walujew ein
glühender anhänger des russischen
diktators und lebt offensichtlich in der
durchtränken propaganda putins
also peter du triffst diesen ihren
russischen boxer musste im wörtlichen
sinne auch noch zu ihm aufschauen ist
ein riese ja auch so begann der box
riese wie war diese begegnung absolut
aus einer anderen welt ich habe danach
wirklich 20 sekunden dagestanden auch
mit die mikro hoch und habe gedacht das
ist doch jetzt alles nicht wirklich
passiert er hat das nicht gesagt dass
das nicht alles gesagt er hatte die
propaganda 121 wiederholt und er hat
dann tatsächlich immer von den nazis
gesprochen es gibt ja den gibt das wort
nationalsozialismus nicht im russischen
vielen anderen osteuropäischen sprachen
auch nicht als es der nazismus damit die
ja nicht sozialismus zu hätten daran
hängt noch aus sowjetzeiten und der
sprache vom nazismus man von den nazis
die hier frieren ich hab ihn dann
gefragt entschuldigung der präsident sie
lenski ist ein jude law und mir wirklich
sagen dass der präsident ein jüdischer
präsidenten nazis und den finger an das
nazi sei nicht an eine ethnie gebunden
sei also nicht an eine rasse gebunden
sei und hat so weitergemacht und habe
noch nie erlebt dass aus einem menschen
in so kurzer zeit so viel propaganda
müll heraus das ist ja unglaublich groß
war meter 13 ich muss mein mikrofon noch
nie so hoch halten und hast du dann
dagegen gehalten was hast du gesagt ich
habe ihm dann schon fragen gestellt aber
strauss und es ist wirklich schwer da
tatsächlich in der rolle als journalist
zu bleiben und nachzufragen und ich
einfach den truppe stets hin zu machen
und nicht auszuflippen weil es ist so
unfassbar so absurd aber er erzählt
exakt das was einem die masse der russen
auf der straße erzählt sie plappern
diesen ganzen quatsch denen sie seit
acht jahren über die ukraine hören
einfach nach was sie glauben dass man
steht davor und ist einfach sprachlos
und
der bessere boxer ist ganz eindeutig
vitali klitschko und wann hast du mir
eines abends peter eine sms geschickt
und hast mir gesagt wir haben die
möglichkeit ein exklusives interview mit
michael kasjanow zu machen ich habe dann
daraufhin kontakt mit ihm aufgenommen
und tatsächlich er hat sich sofort
bereit erklärt das dann auch zu tun ich
habe ihn auch gefragt ob wir sagen
dürfen wo er ist denn ist im exil und er
hat gebeten das lieber nicht zu machen
wir müssen dazu sagen er war der erste
ministerpräsident unter wladimir putin
in dessen amtszeit als erster präsident
dann haben sie sich überworfen um es mal
kurz zu machen er wurde entlassen bekam
auch morddrohungen und sie lebt seitdem
im exil also jemand der putin kennt
deshalb habe ich ihn gefragt wie tickt
putin und wie weit wird er gehen auch
was atomwaffen angeht denn das ist ja
unsere große sorge und das war ein sehr
aufschlussreiches exklusives interview
das sind mit ihm führen konnten
so gut wie jetzt noch fähig ist wir
haben wir sehen es jetzt der selber
diese nachrichten die wir gesehen haben
seine erklärungen sprechen bände
ich sehe immer mit kein ende dieses
krieges und diese verhandlungen die
jetzt laufen da scheint es ja es gibt
positive erwartungen aber ich glaube da
nicht das ist da sehr bald positive
ergebnis ergeben kann aus einem grund
putin braucht den krise und braucht den
sieg und ein neutraler
status ist kein sieg braucht die
anerkennung der krim die ukraine werden
das nie anerkennen dass die krippe mal
so russisches russland unter putin
braucht auch die anerkennung der
unabhängigkeit und auch im endeffekt den
anschluss der donbass territorien an
russland insofern bin ich überzeugt
davon dass die ukraine den ii zustimmt
werden und so fährt kann ich keine
positiven ergebnisse erwarten von diesen
verhandlungen würde putin auch einen
krieg mit der nato und damit letztlich
einen weltkrieg riskieren
nun zunächst sehen sie ja ist und dass
alle westlichen länder
alle nato bündnispartner sich mit großen
mit großer besorgnis in bezug auf die
eigene unterstützung der ukraine
geäußert haben und diesen dieser faktor
führt auch dazu dass er weitermacht den
potenten und weiter seine angriffs auf
wenn sie führte ich glaube das ist nicht
die richtige haltung nicht ganz die
richtige haltung der restlichen
daten in bezug auf die ukraine die
waffenlieferungen müssen fortgesetzt
werden und es müssen die waffen
geliefert werden die den ringen ihren
himmel zu schützen eine flugverbotszone
wäre natürlich die beste lösung aber
sicherlich gibt es da eine risiken ich
glaube allerdings dass jung diesem spiel
die westlichen staaten wirklich
diesen schritt vornehmen sollten eine
flugverbotszone würde eben dazu führen
dass putin echt angst davor hätte das zu
verletzen wie lange kann russland
wirtschaftlich noch durchhalten
das ist eine ernsthafte frage und die
steht tatsächlich auf der tagesordnung
jahr putin hat sich geirrt
hat sich gehört weil er der meinung war
und das hat eben die sein umfeld immer
wieder gesagt dass die reaktion des
westens
vergleichbar wäre wie damals im jahr
2014 oder nicht 2008 die einheit die
einigkeit der europäischen union von der
transatlantischen partner hat putin
verwundert und wirklich schockiert ist
eine ganze mannschaft schockiert die st
jetzt überhaupt das erste mal verhängt
worden sind wie zum beispiel das
einfrieren der finanzpresse zentralbank
ist ein extrem schwerer schlag gegen die
finanzwelt gegen die wirtschaft 400
firmen sind schon aus dem land raus sind
nicht mehr tätig ungefähr 200.000
menschen werden dadurch ihre arbeit
verlieren in den nächsten drei monaten
ja und ich glaube
die sanktionen werden eine wirkung haben
die borussen mercury nächsten monaten
die wirtschaft wird weiter schrumpfen
selbst die vorsichtigsten prognosen dass
das das bip um zehn prozent zurück geht
in diesem jahr das ist gleichbedeutend
mit den 90er jahren was die
geschäftsleitung geht
bereits jetzt fallen ja seit acht jahren
die realen einkommen der bevölkerung
jetzt fallen sie einfach katastrophe
auch durch die geschäfte gegangen du
hast das alles miterlebt wie die regale
immer lehrer wurden
war wirklich von tag zu tag ein die
stündlich also es fing an mit dessen
produkten fällt verschwunden waren
einfach weil die leute gehabt haben so
lange wie es die noch gab war ja klar
war dass viele produkte jetzt
verschwinden werden damit dort ihre
heimstatt dann wurden die nicht
nachgeliefert also die lücken wurden von
tag zu tag größer zum beispiel ganz
einfache sachen ketchup hier sehen wir
in dem bildermarkt das ist eine ist
moskauer zentrum da ist alles mögliche
weg gewesen plötzlich also dann gab es
die großen lücken schon bei milch
russland hat selbst nicht genug milch
für den eigenverbrauch hier hier sehen
wir es mit anna das ist dass das so ein
sohn als sauerkraut spannend die man per
mini und eigentlich auch zu fast jeder
so benimmt weg dann gab sie schlachten
um zucker dann ein laden nach dem
anderen schließt also fängt im
alltäglichen leben an dazu kommen dann
ihre seeverkehr das ist buchweizen das
ist ein grundnahrungsmittel kann man
morgens als prime wird das als risotto
und abends noch mal anders essen das war
das kaufen die leute einfach auch wegen
der inflation weil die preise um bis zu
120 prozent teilweise für
grundnahrungsmittel gestiegen sind wird
gehamstert man klopft sich um den zucker
und es geht einfach durch alles durch
und bis hin zur flugzeuge es gibt bei
den flugzeugen keine ersatzteile mehr
boeing und airbus liefert nicht mehr man
kann nicht mehr fliegen
der maschinenbau ist kurz vor dem aus
man kann keine autos mehr produzieren
selbst leider kann man nicht mehr
herstellen lassen mussten teile aus dem
westen kommen und zum teil sogar
treppenwitz der geschichte aus der
ukraine kommen jetzt müssen sie die
leute sich natürlich fragen warum ist
das so wollen können wir plötzlich
nichts mehr kaufen wissen sie den wahren
grund also der sieht sie kennen einen
grund und den halten sie für den wahren
grund nämlich dass der westen ein völlig
ungerechtfertigten und grundlosen
wirtschaftskrieg gegen irans mit euch in
russland führt da sind nämlich das was
ihnen die propaganda dort erzählt dass
es einen kausalen zusammenhang zwischen
den militärischen sonderoperation in der
ukraine also dem krieg von wladimir
putin ging dem vernichtungskrieg gegen
die ukraine und den sanktionen gibt das
wird ihnen vorenthalten und die denkt
schleifen drehen auch ganz einfach viele
nicht sie gehen in den laden sehen dafür
ein wenig wieder sachen der westen
greift uns wieder an in ihrer
wahrnehmung kämpfte sie ganz alleine
gegen den faschismus in der ukraine der
besten hilft ihnen dabei wieder nicht
wie 1941
und dieses märchen erzählt man sich da
gegenseitig und das erzählt man sich ja
nicht erst seit einem jahr verschwunden
seit 17 das funktioniert
also die eine verlieren ein paar
lebensmittel oder auch anderer
shoppingmöglichkeiten andere sanieren
ihre komplette existenz in der ukraine
insbesondere in der mario pohl der stadt
am asowschen meer der hafen statt der
die nahezu komplett zerstört ist
inzwischen und tausende menschen haben
sich von dort auf gemachte in den westen
sind dann zunächst oft in lemberg
gelangt und in lembeck ist unser kollege
philipp potthoff seit über vier wochen
und ich habe davon gesprochen dass wir
besondere menschen kennengelernt hat und
auch er hat dort besondere menschen
kennen gelernt nämlich eine familie die
gerade aus mario pohl ankam
es ist der dunkelste ort der ukraine der
kessel von mario pohl seit wochen ist
die hafenstadt die etwa so groß wie
duisburg ist von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten russische truppen haben
die stadt eingekesselt bombardieren
wohngebiete und sogar flüchtlingstrecks
einigen gelangen die flucht mit ihnen
hat unser bild reporter philipp potthoff
gesprochen ich stehe hier vor dem
bahnhof in lemberg wo täglich hunderte
oder tausende menschen an kommen aus
allen teilen der ukraine in diesen tagen
kommen vor allem viele menschen aus dem
kessel von mario pohl der stadt an der
küste am asowschen meer die seit wochen
von den russischen truppen belagert wird
eingekesselt ist und von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten und man trifft hier
menschen mit den verschiedensten
geschichten menschen wie ein
hockeyspieler der glück hatte weil er am
februar mit seiner mannschaft mario pohl
verließ um zu einem auswärtsspiel zu
fahren
und dann nicht eingekesselt wurde aber
auch er sorgt sich um seine mutter und
man trifft hier auch familien die
eingekesselt wurden die wochenlang im
bunker saßen wochen lang beschossen
wurden menschen sterben sahen und jetzt
endlich hier angekommen sind und zum
ersten mal seit wochen sich in
sicherheit fühlen in mario pohl kann man
nichts mehr kaufen
die geschäfte haben alle geschlafen
alles hat geschlossen es gibt keine
verbindung nach außen
man weiß nicht was in der ukraine
passiert ob es einen sinn wie mario pohl
zu verlassen man weiß ja nicht wie die
lage in der gesamten ukraine es menschen
die überhaupt kein netz haben decken wir
müssen der ganzen ukraine genauso
es ist alles sehr schwer ich mache mir
um die anderen bewohner von mario krüger
sehr große sorgen sie haben kein essen
kein wasser es ist sogar sehr schwer
wasserholen zu drehen weil die menschen
dabei geschossen werden und sterben wir
hatten keine luftschutzkeller ich hatte
angst verschüttet zu werden unser haus
neben einem hügel da waren wir sehr
lange und vielleicht steht das haus noch
immer
der horror von mario pohl der kreml
fordert die stadt zur kapitulation auf
am montag läuft das ultimatum aus wer
noch in der stadt geblieben ist wird vom
russischen militär als nazi und bandit
betrachtet es droht eine
vernichtungswille wie sie selbst mario
pohl noch nicht erlebt hat doch das
ukrainische militär die ukraine halten
dagegen sie kämpfen für ihr land ihre
freiheit ihr leben ich denke die jungs
nicht mehr sehr sehr stolz auf sie aber
ich mache mir auch große sorgen ich will
dass frieden ich bin dagegen dass die
menschen sterben müssen ich will dass es
überall ruhig und still und schön ist
und unsere kinder glücklich und gesund
aufwachsen
er entkam der krieg solle in mario pohl
nur durch einen zufall hockeyspieler
alexander am 23 februar sind wir zum
auswärtsspiel nach grammatik gefragt
haben ein profiklub mario pohl von dort
sind wir nicht zurückgekehrt am 24
februar sollte das spiel sein wir haben
uns alle vorbereitet aber in der früh
haben die explosion gehört und
verstanden dass die meisterschaft nicht
mehr stattfinden wird oder ein frühstück
kamen der trainer und hat uns gesagt
dass die meisterschaft vorbei ist und
wissen
dann wurde es auch dort gefährlich und
wir haben uns entschlossen weg zu
[Musik]
wir haben die nachrichten verfolgt und
gesehen dass es nicht mehr möglich ist
nach mario pohl rein zu kommen oder die
stadt zu verlassen und man kann auch
nirgendwo hin fahren ich habe gesehen
dass mein haus nun ja nicht mehr
bewohnbar ist in mario pohl sind
hunderttausende zivilisten eingekesselt
laut berichten sind bis zu 90 prozent
der wohnungen zerstört die stadt
komplett in schutt und asche ein
trümmerfeld verantwortet von kreml
diktator wladimir putin er lässt schulen
kindergärten und theater mit
bestialischer brutalität bombardieren
die wasser und stromversorgung gekappt
heizungen gehen nicht mehr
medikamentenlieferungen gibt es nicht
das traurige schicksal seiner mutter
ja meine mutter ist in mario sie ist
leider noch dort wir versuchen in
kontakt zu bleiben aber es gibt kein
netzwerk gerufen bekannte an und wissen
wo sie sich befindet aber es ist nicht
möglich zu ihr zu kommen weil es so
gefährlich ist sich in der stadt zu
bewegen der kampf um mario pohl putin
will die stadt um jeden preis einnehmen
es könnte noch wochen dauern
wenn er diese stadt um jeden preis
einnehmen will peter wochen zerstört er
sie dann weil er sie braucht und zwar
egal wie das ist so wie mit der ukraine
egal wie putin braucht den sieg und
wenn's leben kostet und wenn es große
kriegsverbrechen sind grösste
kriegsverbrechen sind er braucht diese
stadt ist eine strategisch wichtige
hafenstadt er braucht sie als landweg
zur krim 2014 hatte sie verloren da
hatte man die ganz kurz dann ist die
zurück gekämpft worden von den ukrainern
von georgien und die gesamte
schwerindustrie die in der ganzen region
ist bezieht ihre waren und liefert ihre
waren nur über diesen hafen raus und in
der nähe befindet sich noch einer der
wichtigsten getreide helfen darüber
bezieht oder verkauft die ukraine sagt
getreide und verkauft ihr getreide auch
in die ganze welt und schiff das aus und
das letzte mal die mutigen gerade clown
und der braucht mario pohl erstens als
symbol als mini skype den hat den russen
zeigen kann ich habe endlich mario pohl
2014 haben wir es nicht geschafft jetzt
schaffe ich diesen landweg und er
betrachtet die stadt ja auch als
russische libyen gesandte von vasco
mischer weise werden sich diese ganzen
russischen städte doch erheblich dagegen
dass sie von den russen eingenommen
werden und das was ihr mariposa ist
wirklich das paradebeispiel für
schlimmste aller schlimmste
kriegsverbrechen für verstöße gegen alle
regeln die es auf dieser welt gibt
danke für den moment peter wenn man eine
kurze pause und sind gleich wieder da
meine tante